okay Here I am with my tutor some of the
I hope and I should first explain how I
found Sonia - Sonia through my friend
Conor Clyne the language Tsar and he
studied at the Ukrainian language and
culture school of the ants Olivia is the
director of the school she is also a
professor of linguistics at the leaf
National University so she has two jobs
and I was very fortunate to find salumi
a-- she has helped me tremendously and I
thought what we do is we're going to
have a video in English now are we gonna
deal with three questions and then we're
going to have the same three questions
in Ukrainian and you'll see that in my
Ukrainian having a lot of mistakes but I
feel that I have improved but we'll do
the first video in English that will
cover the same questions in Ukrainian
and what's the first question
think about our mass of planning I mean
it's a subjective but when I'll give you
an example of course I studied with you
for about three four months on skype and
then I did a lot of listening and
reading in Ukrainian so I had to sort of
a passive knowledge of the creative I
thought I was pretty good and then I was
in Slovakia in Bratislava and I could I
met some Ukrainians that I couldn't say
a thing I came to the beef and for seven
days every day you have taken me to
museums to all of the main sights here
in the me and every day we spoke for six
hours and after each three-hour section
you had to go home and rest and then you
sent me a list of about 15 phrases which
I imported into link and I studied and I
think as a method of activating one's
personal and learning about a place and
getting massive exposure in the language
I think it's an outstanding method
and I would like to work on this for the
future another it's a lot of passive
learning and some internet you know
Skype discussions and then eventually
going to the country and having this
concentrated interaction with a very
good I should say very good tutor who
corrects me now cuz I want to be
corrected and I continue to make
mistakes but I feel that it has been
very effective thank you you had a great
polyglot who knows fifteen languages and
and in particular Polish and Russian and
Ukrainian language will have bad
influence on your Russian interesting
question in a way I don't yet know
because I haven't gone now just spoken
Russian but I have a feeling that
because all of the structures of
grammatical structures in the Slavic
languages are 90% the same there are
some special things that you create you
nor polish but by and large they're very
similar the same problems herbs of
motion aspects of verbs case endings and
so forth so I feel that my work with you
where you have worked hard to get me to
improve on my accuracy that this is
going to help me in the other languages
I am sure and we'll do this when we
speak in Ukraine and I'll say try to
speak in Russian there will be some
initial interference but I feel in the
long run I'm going to be better in all
my Slavic languages because I studied
Ukraine and I take Ukrainian is in a way
a very useful language because it has
the Cyrillic alphabet like Russian like
Belarusian like Bulgarian it had it's in
terms of its vocabulary is kind of in
between Russian polish Czech so I think
it's actually a good language to focus
on and in order to improve my level if
all my Slavic languages
we will see time will tell me why
Ukrainian if you don't have any opinion
right god you are very interested in
Ukrainian political social economical
and cultural life okay it's interesting
because I think when you study a
language you start to discover a new
world
so Ukraine for me was I would have
almost had trouble finding it automatic
like where's Ukraine what's your pretty
a lot of you don't know that much about
Ukrainian is a part of Russia what is
right once you start studying a language
and I came to pray me because I'd second
chair in Russian first then chair can
enter Ukrainians there's however many 45
50 million people there it's interesting
you start studying a language and with
the language you start reading about the
history and I find an e-book on
Ukrainian history I find an audio book
on Ukrainian history and so I began
discover this world the interesting
history the influence of the original
Kiev grows the into the influence of the
Lithuanian polish Commonwealth and so
forth and the Russian you know czars
Empire and so it just opens up a
fascinating world and you discovered
that Ukraine is its own country with its
whole history with its internal
divisions and so forth and it just it
just grows on you there's an expression
in French which I always use black
patina on Jean so any language whether
it be Czech or Ukrainian the more you
study the more you learn not only about
the language about the people and I
think that Ukraine
it's I think it's in terms of area the
largest company in Europe 45 50 million
people is a lot of people rich history
kind of with connections to Poland with
connections our Russia with connections
to even to sort of the austro-german ik
world because part of Poland are part of
the Ukraine was part of the
austro-hungarian Empire so it's a unique
cross word a crossroad it's a unique
crossroad so I found it very rewarding
if that answers your question thank you
very much okay thank you and we're gonna
try to do the same have the same
discussion in Ukrainian I'll make lots
of mistakes so please don't ask me for
subtitle it's a lot of work to do that
instead you'll be able to follow the
same discussion in your cranium bye for
now
[Music]